- [Teacher] I am
- [Students] I am
- [Teacher] somebody.
- [Students] somebody.
- [Woman] He does everything
to get us to college.
- All that I care about
is winning.
I am
- [Students] I am
- somebody.
- [Students] somebody.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together six biracial people.
- I'm biracial.
- I am biracial.
- [Narrator] One of them is white.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
(upbeat music)
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the odd one out?
(upbeat music)
- So should we start with,
what are you mixed with?
- Yeah, what's your ethnic background?
- Basically, my mom is Indian
and then my dad is white.
- Oh, okay.
- So, I'm whindian.
(group laughs)
- Oh, my God.
- I'm half Taiwanese, half white, so.
- That's cool.
I'm half Korean, half white.
- Okay.
I'm a fourth Black and
then my mom's white.
- I'm half Black and half
French, but white. (chuckles)
- I was kind of suspicious
of Daria and Ella.
The hair, I felt like it
was kind of a distraction,
like as a ploy.
- I'm half Native
American and half Mexican.
- How did your parents meet?
- My parents met at a movie theater.
My mom was working there
and my dad came in,
and he just had a crush on her.
So he'd always keep coming
back and just watching movies.
- That's really wholesome.
- Yeah.
(group chuckles)
- My dad was a tennis coach
at University of Central Missouri,
and my mother was an international
student learning tennis.
So that's how they met.
- International student.
You threw that in there.
(group chuckles)
Okay, I see it.
- She said, "Oh, you mentioned
international student,"
so I thought she was targeting me,
so I thought, "Mm, okay.
Maybe she's the mole."
- My parents met in grad school.
They both went to Georgia Tech.
My dad's from Georgia, but
my mom immigrated from France
to go to grad school in the U.S.
So they just met each other
in the engineering department.
- My parents met at a barbecue.
My dad was in the military,
so he was in Osan Air Base in South Korea.
And my mom was at that barbecue
because she lived near Osan.
She would tell me about it.
She was like, "Yeah, I thought
Americans were really weird
because your dad showed up
in shorts and flip flops
and a button up tee
with a Russian bear hat
and it was winter."
(group chuckles)
And I was just like,
"And then you ended up marrying him."
She's like, "Yeah." (chuckles)
- How nice.
My parents met in LA, which
is like the mixing pot.
So makes sense, I guess, yeah.
- She had said that her
parents had met in LA,
but she didn't really elaborate on that.
Everyone else had kind
of gone into more detail
about their parents,
and I felt like that was a little strange.
- My parents are both from Arizona.
They met, I would say at
a bar, I think. (titters)
So yeah, my mom is from the
Navajo Nation reservation.
- We got through the questions.
(timer rings)
- Okay, we got through
the questions.
(upbeat music)
- I was just noticing
that she seemed nervous,
and she didn't have a lot of details.
(upbeat music)
- On a most simplistic standpoint,
Ella looked the whitest,
even though obviously
it's not truly about that.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] We have a three-way tie.
(group gasps)
- Oh, wow.
- [Host] Between Ella, Caitlyn and Daria.
You guys are gonna have
30 seconds on the clock
to just kind of prove your case.
- So my hair, I have a Afro
normally, but it's all braided
and I added in extensions
just 'cause it's easier,
but I have 4b curls,
which I would only know if I was mixed.
I get that from my dad.
Everything else is white because, I mean,
my dad's half Belgian and half Black,
and then my mom's fully white.
So I just, unfortunately, I'm Xerox paper
and I don't even tan,
but it's all in my hair.
I promise.
(timer rings)
- My mom's from France.
She's from a place called
Vannes in Brittany.
And then my dad grew
up in Devereux Georgia,
but I actually also grew up in Arizona
because they moved there and had me
and my younger brother, younger sister.
My sister and I are kind of the palest,
while my brother actually looks
like (chuckles) he's Black.
So yeah, it's a weird
liminal space to be in.
(timer rings)
- What I was gonna say before,
is that my mom is from the
Navajo Nation reservation,
and my dad is Mexican.
He just grew up in Arizona.
So, you know,
I have equal
balances in both, I guess.
Yeah.
(timer rings)
(suspenseful music)
- She started, you know, kind of giggling
or laughing in her story.
And I thought, "Hmm, there's
something suspicious here."
(suspenseful music)
(buzzer buzzing)
- Dang. All right.
Good luck, guys.
- It was nice talking to you.
- Nice talking to you.
- Yeah.
- The fact that I'm pale,
I thought, you know,
might have gotten me voted out.
- [Host] Raise your hand if
you think the mole is still
in the box and you'd wish
to continue the game.
- I have a question,
- Yeah.
- 'cause you said that
you were growing up quapa
or, sorry, 'cause you're a quarter, right?
- Oh, oh, that's what it's called?
- Oh, yeah. (chuckles)
- That's good to know.
- I have a friend that's quapa.
I guess like, what was that like for you?
As far as I know, as biracial person,
it's like you feel like an imposter
in your own culture sometimes.
- Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I'm the lightest
of me and my siblings.
I have a younger sister, who's
like the color of Rhianna,
and then my brother is super tan.
And so, then there's me,
white girl with a giant Afro,
and people are always like,
"How is your hair so frizzy?"
I'm like, "Well, it's
curly. It's an Afro."
You know, explaining to people who I am.
It was hard at times.
But then I also was really proud
that I got to say like,
"Oh, I'm part Black.
That's why I have this cool hair."
But it took me a while
to really love who I am.
- Have the rest of you
guys felt like that too?
- One thing I felt is like,
I've actually been to
India multiple times,
and whenever I go, I'm
the lightest one there.
So I just don't feel
Indian at all, really.
- He said that he had been to India,
and he just kinda threw that out there
and that felt really quick.
And just like a, but there
wasn't any detail to the story.
- Yeah, for me, being from Colorado,
my experience has always being
too Asian to be white here
in Colorado, but here at
UCLA, where I'm at right now,
where it's a lot more diverse,
I'm feeling like sometimes
I'm too white to be Asian.
So no matter what, I always
feel exclusion from one side.
And I think that's one of the struggles
or one of the experiences
of being biracial.
- I don't know.
I think when I was younger,
I was a little more ambiguous looking,
like people would kind of joke
I was like a chameleon growing up
'cause I didn't look the
same every couple of years.
But it was like, I would
always get made fun of a lot
by other Korean students
who would say like,
there's like slurs for biracial people.
And so it was always like,
"Oh, people like you
just shouldn't exist,"
and stuff like that.
- I'm so sorry.
- Yeah.
- Still here. (chuckles)
(group chuckles)
- I grew up in predominantly
white neighborhoods
my whole life.
And I don't speak Spanish.
I don't speak Navajo.
I never had a quinceañera, (titters)
so I'm not really like a
hundred percent in each culture.
- Yeah.
- For me, growing up
mostly with my mom's family
who's majority white,
and then my dad's family
lives farther away.
So, soul food and all that stuff,
I kinda missed out on,
and I got to kinda explore later in life.
But that's something
that I always wish I had.
(timer ticking)
- I'm glad we all get to talk.
- Yeah, that was a good discussion.
(timer rings)
(upbeat music)
His story was not as consistent.
There were some things
that had some detail,
and then some other things
that were a lot less detailed.
(upbeat music)
(buzzer buzzes)
- Oh.
Damn.
Sucks to lose, but it's all good.
- [Host] Raise your hand if
you think the mole is still
in the box and you would
like to continue the game.
- When the group eliminated Devin,
I think we found the mole.
I think we're good now.
- [Host] If the light turns green,
that means you have voted
the mole out and you all win.
However, if the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
(group laughs nervously)
- Heart's racing.
(suspenseful upbeat music)
Oh, cool, cool.
(group cheering)
- [All] Woo!
(group applauding)
- Gas money for everybody.
- Yeah.
(group chuckles)
- [Host] Will the mole
please reveal themselves
in 3,
2,
1.
(tense music)
(group exclaims)
- I'm Lebanese, Arab, Middle Eastern,
(chuckles) which is
technically white in the US.
People from North Africa, so like Egypt,
Tunisia, Algeria, et cetera,
and people from the Middle
East are considered white
on the U.S. census.
So it really goes to show
how arbitrary (chuckles)
the term white is,
in the ways in which
it's applied to people.
- I always think it's
silly that on the census
it's Black, white, Asian.
The categories are so limited,
and so when I'm doing the census,
I just put white because
I look like I'm white.
It just goes to show you
that no matter what somebody looks like,
you could be biracial, like your hair.
I would've thought, "Okay, I
could believe that you're mixed
'cause you have the curly
hair," but you never know.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
(group chattering)
- [All] Woo!
(group laughing)
- I always wanted to do this.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
I gotta perfect this.
- Someone's good at this.
- Yeah.
- That was good.
- That was really hard.